i always thank my my honorees for being
a good sport afterwards because it's not
easy right you know
have you ever been roasted i've never
been roasted i get roasted every day
every day um i have uh
when my when i had a writing staff i did
feel because i would go in and they
would just go to town
um
if i made if i slipped up or if i made
any mistake at all during a taping i
would hear about it and they delighted
in it
but i also delighted in going after them
then so uh there was a lot of that that
i think to your point
when you're done with something like
that you almost felt like you've been to
a spa
because you get the bile like the bile
literally comes out of your pores
uh and i i find it to be um
there's something really magical about
it when it goes well when it goes really
well and uh it's one of the things that
why i brought up the how the person
reacts is so key
because you're giving them a gift if
they see it that way
go ahead go ahead if you can laugh at
yourself if you can laugh during that
it's it's kind of joyous and when you're
done i always say to the honoree i said
if you're having fun everyone's going to
have fun right and and and
and to your point
their laugh
can also make the joke better my most
famous joke when i was a young comedian
was at the roast of jerry stiller friars
rose i've heard about this is b arthur i
want to hear this please please say this
please say this so um this is like 1999
or something i'm just starting to get a
little bit of a reputation around new
york for doing the roasts and i loved it
because here i was doing shows with
milton berle and buddy hacking
and and and and you know of course my my
hip friends in the old comedy scene were
making fun of me but i was like this is
the ultimate alternative comedy like i'm
up here with these you know mount roast
more of comedy
well you guys are out there you know in
these without a microphone in these like
alt bars and i'm like i'm gonna come up
here and get made fun of by milton berle
and uh at this point now i'm like you
know a comedy central i don't know what
they would call it consultant like i
would help if kevin james was gonna
roast jerry stiller i was gonna write
kevin set my set jerry set like i worked
months 24 7. you know i did it all was
like uh you know fresh baked daily jokes
here's the latest and this is your
speech and this is your speech everybody
would have input and you know i'd work
with everybody to make sure they owned
it and felt it
but i was all in on these shows and
bea arthur was one of my
idols i just loved her and she
the the the friars club would have the
podium in the middle and then the deus
would go 40 people each side like an
airplane wing you know like and and you
know freddie roman would get up and it
would introduce everyone there for 20
minutes everyone would take a bow and uh
um i did the same joke every year when
freddie would introduce donald trump on
the dais i would stand up and wave just
as donald did as one moment of the night
i would always take his moment and act
like i was him and wave to the it was
like you know 2 000 it was a good sport
even then yeah sure
yeah and uh you know howard and robin
they'd be up in the balcony and you know
it was like a who's who of politics and
boxers and all of it was it was always
this is i love that i want that it was
just all these new york um socialites
and stuff
and bea arthur shows up because she's
friends with you know anne meera and
jerry stiller so she's a guest and she's
on the dais
and of course i'm towards the end of the
show and no one's other than her little
bow in the beginning no one's mentioned
be arthur and i'm like that is
disrespectful
i'll fix this
i know what you said i have my script
there's no teleprompters
i have my script and and i don't know
what i was thinking or where it came
from but in my nervous scroll
um just somewhere in my margin i wrote b
arthur's dick
and i sat there another 30 minutes that
note just sold at sotheby's
for six hundred thousand dollars
and one of my friends from the friars
club one of the board members joe
zappala he was the ambassador to spain
uh you know he's sitting next to me an
older guy and i and i show him i just i
point on the paper to him next to me it
just says be art and he looks like no no
no
he'll ruin this perfectly guys you were
warned this perfectly nice evening
and
then i look at him like man you know i
should have asked a comic not an
ambassador
and uh
and i finally wait my turn and
and i'm next and sandra bernhard who i
love is up there and she's
doing a risque uh sort of lap dance
thing to jerry you know and you know
writhing around uh jerry and you know he
doesn't he's very squeamish he was very
embarrassed and that was the joke is how
he got uncomfortable yeah and his son is
there and his daughter's there and his
wife and mirror is there and the whole
thing and uh is just delightful and
hilarious and weird and totally sandra
and then they introduced me and i said
my opening joke was i couldn't help
myself sandra bernhard holy [ __ ] i
wouldn't [ __ ] you would be arthur's dick
the joke's okay yeah to me the joke's
okay
but the the it's like you say about
rickles it's the balls of it yes you
know but it's the the brazenness part of
it but but
it was her reaction
that made it yes my made my triple into
a grand slam yeah it was she she she
just
slow burned me
and the camera held on her and she just
didn't just
evil eye just
just
she murdered me by just looking at me
right and that made
everything okay like she gave a classic
golden girls like slow burn take perfect
and she really made it perfect and you
know a year goes by you know that year
like time out in new york jokes of the
year it makes the end of the year thing
like moments and i'm like oh my god i'm
getting famous off this be arthur joke i
wonder if she's hearing about it
so now i'm like oh my god i hope she's
not upset you know i love the arthur to
think that i would embarrass her or hurt
her in any way like she was a good sport
but maybe on the inside is she getting
asked about this in interviews because
the roasts were starting to take off to
become this like cultural
thing
and i see that she's performing her
one person show in los angeles
uh it's a fundraiser for an animal
charity and
i didn't have a lot of money back then
and the tickets were expensive and i got
one ticket i went by myself
and i brought flowers and somehow i
weaseled my way backstage and she had a
long line of well-wishers who wanted to
congratulate her and i waited to go last
so that i could actually talk to her and
uh i gave her the flowers and
i said miss arthur it's like a year
later i don't know if you remember me
but we met at jerry's roast and she said
you nailed me you prick
[Laughter]
it for you but good for you for going
beautiful and the best lay i ever had
like a horse
roast in peace
roast in peace be arthur
i loved her she was so cool